merci beaucoup d'être notre invitée ce
matin on sait que les nuits sont courtes
au Sénat en ce moment merci de vous être
levé de bonheur c'est natrice socialiste
du Nord vice-présidente de la délégation
au droit des femmes on va bien sûr
parler de cette séance agité dans
quelques instants mais d'abord un mot
sur la mobilisation d'hier plus fort que
j'en ai de mobilisation au nombre de
manifestants un million 280000 selon le
ministère de l'Intérieur 3,5 millions
selon la CGT et pourtant le gouvernement
semble rester inflexible cette
mobilisation a-t-elle vraiment une
utilité bien sûr elle montre qu'une
réforme a été aussi rarement aussi
rejeté par l'ensemble des catégories
sociales l'ensemble des générations la
réforme du travail le peuple n'en veut
pas et il la redit hier et il va le
redire pendant je crois le reste de la
semaine au moins jusque samedi ou un
nouveau mouvement est annoncé il faut
monter
en graduation dans ces mouvements est-ce
que vous êtes pour des blocages est-ce
que vous êtes pour des grèves rec
possible mais la question n'est pas
tellement de savoir s'il faut monter
c'est plutôt que la situation
l'autisme du gouvernement le blocage des
discussions même au Sénat
montent montrent que nous ne sommes pas
entendus le peuple n'est pas entendu et
par conséquent la colère monte et il ne
faut pas s'en étonner elle peut monter
jusqu'où cette colère selon vous elle
peut aller je le regrette
personnellement jusqu'à un blocage où on
voit bien que des catégories qui
n'étaient pas concernées le sont
maintenant je pense au raffinerie par
exemple je pense aux routier d'autres
catégories professionnelles vont
s'associer au mouvement des lycéens
peut-être également des étudiants et on
craint on peut craindre une contagion du
mouvement les syndicats demandent à être
sûr en urgence par Emmanuel Macron nous
ont raison ce serait la moindre des
choses que la première ministre que le
Président de la République reçoivent
l'Inter syndical ce serait vraiment la
moindre des choses qui les reçoivent qui
les écoutent mais également qu'ils les
entendent et qu'il modifie son projet en
conséquence c'est ce que nous attendons
et justement on va parler de ce projet
puisque les sénateurs l'examinent
évidemment en ce moment même et hier
vous avez débuté l'examen du fameux
article 7 sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à 64 ans et la nuit a été très
agitée dans l'hémicycle on va voir ça
avec Steve Jordan
[Musique]
bonjour madame la sénatrice et suivre le
Sénat avec une nuit de rebondissement
ouais on s'attendait au grand soir de la
gauche sénatoriale et on a eu il y a une
longue nuit pour tous les autres groupes
on a finalement eu le droit à une courte
nuit à l'occasion de laquelle la droite
a rappelé qui était le maître des
horloges ici au Sénat tout a commencé à
19h hier les sénateurs décident alors
d'entamer l'article 7 de la réforme des
retraites le fameux article qui prévoit
le recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans l'occasion pour la
gauche de dire ce qu'elle pense de la
réforme l'occasion aussi pour la
mobilisation de s'inviter dans les
missiles qui coûtait
je vous le dis sincèrement ce recours à
cette procédure est un acte de faiblesse
de la part de la droite
sénatoriale c'est une marque de
fébrilité qui vous qui parcourt vos
rangs comme elle parcourt les rangs du
gouvernement
on avait un autre son prévu on va dire
pour être honnête c'est pas grave on va
enchaîner s'ils sur l'article 7 beaucoup
d'amendements avaient été déposés par la
gauche 1300 amendements au total c'est
beaucoup c'est énorme sur ces 1300
amendements 77 étaient des amendements
dit de suppression c'est-à-dire des
amendements dont l'objectif et de dire
niet non au report de las légal de
départ à la retraite ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que chaque examen
d'amendement prend du temps puisque les
orateurs de gauche peuvent prendre
successivement la parole pour afficher
leur position pendant ce temps-là à la
droite prend son mal en patience mais à
minuit 58 Bruno retaille on a un peu
marre c'est un rappel au règlement
monsieur le Président à partir c'est sur
la base de l'article 38 77 amendements
de suppression
tous
identique monsieur le Président je
demande cette application
article 38 du Règlement du Sénat qui
veut 38 qui permet de clôturer la
discussion parlementaire c'est-à-dire de
limiter le temps de parole par
amendement ou par article un pour un
contre c'est un dispositif qui est assez
nouveau puisqu'il date une réforme de
2015 et qu'il n'avait jamais été utilisé
auparavant alors évidemment
l'utilisation a provoqué la colère de la
gauche alors qu'est-ce qui se passe à ce
moment-là et ben c'était pas une
surprise déjà de l'utilisation de cette
article 38 puisque et bien c'était à peu
près vu la droite vous avez un peu
prévenu madame filleul qu'elle allait
l'utiliser alors il est autour d'une
heure et quart ensuite on va un peu
avancer dans les débats Gérard lâcher
décide de suspendre la séance après une
demande de la gauche mais petit coup de
théâtre pendant cette suspension la
commission des affaires sociales se
réunit pour réécrire l'article 7 une
réécriture qui aura pour conséquence et
bien de faire passer à la trappe tous
les amendements de la gauche la gauche
qui ne se laisse pas faire riposte en
déposant plusieurs milliers de nouveaux
amendements qui seront tous jugés
irrecevables à l'exception d'un seul
sensu alors un moment de flottement dans
les muscle écoutez
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
déposer des sous amendements
nous allons procéder au vote
[Musique]
voilà pourquoi alors on a le droit de
déposer j'ai le droit de souder un
amendement
il est 3h du matin Paris dort toujours
la gauche proteste contre les méthodes
de la majorité sénatoriale Gérard
Larcher décide à nouveau de suspendre la
séance à la reprise des trois présidents
des groupes de gauche vont tout
simplement quitter l'hémicycle la séance
est levée le Sénat va se coucher sans
avoir terminé l'examen de l'article 7 il
faudra attendre cet après-midi avant que
les débats ne reprennent dans
l'hémicycle autour de la mesure d'âge
souhaitée par Emmanuel Macron madame la
sénatrice à qui la faute
que l'opposition
[Applaudissements]
à jouer son rôle à défendu à un projet à
un projet de société une conception de
la retraite a souhaité que le débat
puisse se dérouler à l'Assemblée
nationale pour toutes les raisons que
l'on sait le débat n'avait pas été à la
hauteur de la situation et les Français
attendaient que le débat se déroule sur
tous les articles du projet de loi du
gouvernement
vous n'avez pas eu assez la parole parce
qu'on a vu quand même je vais rappeler
1300 amendements sur l'article 7 mais
vous le savez le gouvernement a choisi
une modalité un véhicule législatif qui
cadre le débat et qui le limite et donc
moi je voudrais redire que la première
obstruction ça a été l'obstruction du
gouvernement en imposant cette modalités
de débats et vraiment moi je pense que
le
Sénat ne sort pas grandi de cette nuit
en fait il y avait une grande espérance
une grande attente de débat et
finalement et bien on a vu qu'on
utilisant tous ces moyens de censure
quelque part du débat et bien la
majorité signatoriale a rejoint quelque
part le projet du gouvernement devient
complice du projet du gouvernement et
contribue quelque part à faire grandir
le mécontentement sauf que la majorité
sénatorielle elle veut aller jusqu'au
bout du texte on n'est pas caché elle
dit qu'il y a d'autres articles à
examiner que l'article 7 est-ce que la
gauche n'a pas fait une erreur en ne
commençant pas cet article 7 plutôt
est-ce qu'il aurait pas fallu le
commencer plus tôt pour avoir plus de
temps de débats sur cet article mais cet
article c'est comme le disait mes
collègues c'est le cœur du réacteur le
cœur de la réforme les Français ont
montré qu'ils ne voulaient pas
travailler plus longtemps et c'est
vraiment sur cet article et sur cette
condition que le projet achoppe et donc
il fallait y consacrer un maximum de
temps les Français ne veulent pas
travailler plus longtemps tout d'abord
parce qu'un certain nombre sont déjà
usés à 64 ans le corps a souffert
pendant des années d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de professions et de métiers
ne sont déjà plus vivants à 64 ans et
puis d'autres ont envie et bien de
pouvoir profiter de ces deux meilleures
années de retraite et donc c'était
normal qu'on y consacre un maximum
d'arguments et vous avez pu voir comme
moi que la défense des amendements et
que les amendements eux-mêmes avaient du
sens et avait chacun leur argumentaire
77 amendements de suppression donc pour
dire non à recul du départ du recul de
là de départ à la retraite est-ce que
c'est pas trop est-ce que un bon
observateur donc de la vie parlementaire
vous avez vu que ces différents rejets
et bien avaient des motivations
différentes avec des documentaire
différents et était tous étayés et
valable ce n'était pas comme on a pu le
dire à un moment donné de l'obstruction
pour de l'obstruction pour vous ce qui
s'est passé
la défense d'une conception de la
société d'une conception de la retraite
oui mais vous saviez que le temps était
contraint est-ce que comme dit Steve il
aurait pas fallu en faire moins moins
d'amendement moins d'amendements
suppression pour avoir plus de temps de
débats en somme limiter limiter le débat
limiter la discussion parlementaire non
ça fait partie du jeu ça fait partie de
la démocratie et limiter le débat c'est
limiter la démocratie et j'allais dire
que ça suffit aujourd'hui il faut
laisser les parlementaires s'exprimer il
faut écouter les forces syndicales il
faut écouter les 3 millions et demi de
personnes qui sont exprimées hier en
défilant dans la rue d'une manière
disciplinée d'une manière
mais les collègues de du Parti
communiste enfin du groupe communiste on
levait des affiches mais pour pas en
retrait oui ne partez pas ne partez pas
en retraite ne partons pas en retraite à
64 ans mais pour les retirer aussi
rapidement ça a duré quoi même pas 30
secondes et encore une fois nous nous
avons quitté la séance pour que
justement aujourd'hui les débats
commencent dans la sérénité et
recommence dans la série pour
recommencer dans la sérénité pour vous à
16h30 sur cet article bien sûr avec le
souci permanent du débat et nous le
disons nous voulons que le débat ait
lieu et lieu jusqu'au bout et surtout
les articles également ça on va y venir
mais est-ce que vous ne reculez pas vous
ne reculiez pas aussi le vote sur cet
article 7 de peur d'être battu mais
j'allais dire que la majorité
sénatoriale et ce qu'elle est on la
connaît ce que l'on veut c'est avoir le
débat
pouvoir faire notre travail de sénateur
de parlementaires jusqu'au bout et que
les Français puissent mesurer un qui
souhaite qu'il parte en retraite plus
tard vous souhaitez un vote sur
l'ensemble du texte nous souhaitons que
le débat ait lieu sur tous les articles
nous verrons comment le débat évolue et
comment la majorité sénatoriale gère ce
débat et vous la gauche c'est elle et
c'est elle qui a la main mais nous on
faire notre travail pas que qu'est-ce
que vous allez faire sur les articles à
venir sur les carrières longues sur la
pénibilité sur les 1200 euros est-ce que
là aussi vous allez rentrer dans une
stratégie de ralentissement des débats
mais ce n'est pas une stratégie de
ralentissement des débats partout
donnez-moi c'est nous faisons notre
travail nous avons des arguments nous
avons une vision de la société une
vision des retraites qui est différente
et nous tenons à développer
nos arguments jusqu'au bout au final
vous savez que cette réforme passera
vous la redoutez
moi je souhaite que le gouvernement et
que le Président de la République
entendent ce qui se passe dans son pays
il n'entend pas il n'écoute pas et
j'allais dire que moi ce que je souhaite
c'est plutôt que le Président de la
République finisse par entendre ce qui
se passe et qu'il arrête attend son
projet en fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit il
faut une dissolution un référendum vous
dites la même chose bah moi je dis que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a toujours de
mauvaise idée et propose de mauvaises
solutions moi je pense que compte tenu
de la de la fébrilité de du peuple de la
de ce qu'est la nation le pays en ce
moment je pense que ce ne serait pas le
bon moment non pour une dissolution il y
aura une commission mixparitaire à la
semaine prochaine qui doit trouver un
accord entre députés et sénateurs vous
pensez que cet accord sera trouvé
qu'elle sera conclusive cette CMP mais
c'est très difficile à dire aujourd'hui
je pense que
on ne me peut difficilement anticiper
sur ce qui se passera à la CMP
serait-elle conclusive cela dépend aussi
des avancées que le gouvernement
pourrait concéder à ce moment-là et des
républicains toujours de l'espoir je
suis positive et j'espère donc vous
souhaitez qu'elle soit conclusive
j'espère que du débat n'être à la
lumière et qu'à un moment donné ben il y
aura des amendements et des
améliorations qui rendront cette réforme
acceptable et on viendront
principalement la loi particulièrement
sur l'âge de la retraite bien évidemment
on va parler des droits des femmes dans
quelques instants puisque nous sommes le
8 mars les sénateurs les républicains
veulent une surcotte de 5% pour les
mères de famille après 63 ans est-ce que
ça c'est quelque chose que vous allez
voter
probablement mais c'est un pialet en
fait ce n'est pas satisfaisant on sait
bien que la réforme va voir pour victime
de manière très importante
les femmes puisque le gouvernement
recherche 18 milliards d'économies on
dit qu'il y en a 11 milliards qui se
feront sur le dos des femmes et en
particulier par la disparition de cette
compensation que représentait les
trimestres accordés à la naissance de
chaque enfant puisque l'allongement du
temps de travail et bien rend inopérant
cette forme de compensation je rappelle
22% de différence de salaire entre les
hommes et les femmes 40% au moment de la
retraite et ce n'est pas cette surcote
de 5% qui a été retrouvé en dernière
minute qui va compenser la situation on
va continuer à parler de ces questions
vers Mercier Steve tout à l'heure on
parlera du retour de clivage
droite-gauche évidemment on reverra des
extraits de cette séance agitée on
disait aujourd'hui journée des droits
des femmes vous êtes vice-présidente de
la délégation Sénat on va continuer
on a parlé de ces questions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Brive en Corrèze retrouver pomme la
brousse bonjour pomme merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pommes du journal La
Montagne et vous copier le thé un groupe
de travail sur la place des femmes dans
vos contenus éditoriaux en cette Journée
des droits des femmes édition spéciale
dans tous les titres du groupe Centre
France
c'est vrai ce matin parce que nous
sommes le 8 mars les 9 quotidiens du
groupe Centre France se posent très
franchement et avec un peu d'impatience
je ne vous le cache pas la question
suivante l'égalité c'est pour quand tout
simplement parce que c'est aujourd'hui
la Journée internationale des droits des
femmes vous l'avez dit c'est pas la
journée de la femme celle qui sert à
vendre des fleurs et des aspirateurs
mais la journée où on fait le point sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
aux manettes de cette édition spéciale
nous sommes donc un collectif d'une
trentaine de journalistes femmes et
hommes de tous les titres du groupe ce
collectif est né il y a presque deux ans
de l'envie de réfléchir de mesurer la
place que l'on fait dans nos textes nos
photos nos vidéos à celles qui composent
tout de même la moitié de la société il
y a plusieurs sujets sur lesquels se
collectif travaille et pour celui de
mars on a justement voulu aller plus
loin que la ribambelle de portraits
féminins que l'on trouve souvent dans
les journaux ce jour là d'une part parce
que ces portraits de parcours admirable
étonnant ou rare et bien on peut très
bien les proposer tous les autres jours
de l'année d'ailleurs on le fait mais
aussi parce qu'on voulait revenir à
l'essentiel à l'ADN de cette journée ces
questions de droit et d'égalité dans ce
dossier spécial qui se décline aussi sur
nos sites Internet nous avons réuni 6
pages de témoignages de reportage pour y
voir plus clair Marie porte Lanaud par
exemple nous raconte ce qui s'est passé
après la sortie de son documentaire je
ne suis pas une je suis une
journaliste qui a provoqué une
déflagration on s'en souvient on s'est
aussi invité dans une classe de Philo
dans un lycée du département de l'Yonne
pour essayer de savoir ce qu'il y a dans
les téléphones de nos ados et ce qu'ils
en pensent
et au-delà des chiffres des différents
baromètres pour voir comment se
manifeste le sexisme ordinaire on a posé
la même question à huit femmes la plus
jeune à 17 ans la plus âgée 90 on leur a
demandé de nous raconter la dernière
fois où elle ne s'était pas sentie
légale d'un homme te raconter en fait
cet instant où on se prend en pleine
figure l'injustice de l'inégalité
écoutez ce qu'elle nous a répondu
la dernière fois que je me suis pas
senti légal d'un homme c'est arrivé ici
au stade à mon travail un client m'a dit
que effectivement mon métier était plus
facile parce que j'ai élevé des brebis
et que ce serait probablement plus
difficile pour moi d'élever des vaches
on m'a dit oui mais le gardiennage c'est
fait pour les hommes dans un bar où on
avait accepté de bouquet sauf que la
surprise c'est qu'on n'a pas été
rémunéré pour fournir un spectacle
c'était en train de créer l'association
un responsable de la ville de Clermont
m'avait dit oh là là son truc il va pas
tenir trois mois nous les vestiaires ont
été les toilettes on a même pas eu accès
à un verre d'eau mais il y a des
boissons d'offerte
parce qu'on devait faire nos preuves
j'ai toujours menée à bien mes projets
par me disant que je suis une femme et
qu'il faut que je fasse mes profs face
aux hommes mais parce que j'y vais tout
par patio
tous ces témoignages
tous ces témoignages pardon sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
dans nos éditions et d'ailleurs
j'aimerais en profiter pour vous poser
la même question Martin filleul si vous
êtes d'accord vous voulez vous nous
raconter la dernière fois où vous ne
vous êtes pas sentis légal d'un homme
mais je vous avoue que je n'ai pas de
fait précis à vous raconter mais que je
voudrais vous vous transmettre ce
ressenti à propos du monde politique
en vous disant que chaque jour et à
chaque instant les femmes politiques
sentent bien qu'elles sont dans un monde
d'homme un monde créé par les hommes
organisés par les hommes mais pour les
hommes et qu'elles ont à chaque instant
et à chaque moment la nécessité de faire
leurs preuves et de et de montrer
qu'elles sont à la hauteur de la
situation et quelque part ça c'est une
pression qui est permanente pour elle
et qui visiblement ne trouvera pas de
solutions rapidement il faut que les
femmes soient plus nombreuses dans la
vie politique et qu'elle s'implique dans
la vie politique pour que les
pour qu'elle prenne vraiment toutes
leurs places et qu'elle puisse gagner
aussi en confiance et en assurance et
pas que dans la vie politique dans les
dans la vie publique aussi dans les
responsabilités sont déposez une
proposition de loi vous à ce sujet le
contenu est toujours pas mais toujours
pas non même dans la dans la fonction
publique qu'on croit exemplaire a priori
au niveau des salaires et au niveau de
l'égalité homme-femme et bien le compte
n'y est pas il y a des ministères en
particulier qui sont connus pour être
plus difficiles d'accès pour les femmes
d'ailleurs et ce sera peut-être le scoop
du jour il y a des ministères qui paient
des amendes parce qu'elles il ne
respecte pas la parité entre les hommes
et les femmes au niveau de la haute
fonction publique vous les connaissez
j'imagine ces ministère oui ce sont les
ministères masculins traditionnellement
qui sont les mêmes quel que soit le
gouvernement ou
vous voyez des différences dans l'accès
à la parité si on est dans un
gouvernement de droite un gouvernement
de gauche c'est ouvert de monde
hydrotique en ce moment
mais il y a effectivement des
différences et des évolutions et il y a
surtout des ministères qui s'organisent
avec la loi pour changer le périmètre
des postes concernés par exemple par les
statistiques sur la parité donc il
essaye de contourner la langue oui et ça
du coup dans votre proposition de loi
elle sera examinée dans moins d'un mois
au sein de l’émitique qu'est-ce que ça
peut changer qu'est-ce que ça va changer
parce qu'il y a déjà eu une loi un peu
dans ce sens la loi sauvader il y a 10
ans il y a une loi faite par
Jean-François Copé qui va vous succéder
pour qu'il y ait des quotas de femmes
dans les conseils d'administration
pourquoi on y arrive toujours pas et
bien on va dire que c'est loin on fait
évoluer notamment la situation mais que
ce n'est pas suffisant et en particulier
si on prend l'exemple de la loi sauvader
c'est parce que le critère qui a été
choisi par la loi sauvadée c'est le
critère des primo nominations et on voit
que ce n'est pas le bon critère de la
société de d'appréciation et qu'il faut
se baser sur le nombre échec actif de
femmes qui sont en poste parce que parmi
les prix monominés c'est un peu
technique mais parmi les primo nominés
les femmes en l'occurrence et bien ne
restent pas forcément dans le poste
concerné et donc ça fait bouger
considérablement le nombre de femmes en
poste un dernier mot sur ce sujet
Emmanuel Macron a prévu de rendre
aujourd'hui un hommage à Gisèle Halimi
avocate militante féministe c'est
dommage fait polémique sur le fait qu'il
soit rendu en ce moment en pleine
contestation sur la réforme des
retraites le chef de l'État est accusé
d'instrumentalisation vous partagez ça
je pense surtout qu'on a beaucoup de
tergiverser à propos de la
panthéonisation de Gisèle
encore très peu de femmes qui sont au
Panthéon je crois qu'il y en a six
aujourd'hui et vraiment moi je milite
pour que Gisèle Halimi puisse faire
partie de ce petit nombre des femmes qui
soient panthéonisées elles le mérite
bien par son combat de la même manière
moi je milite pour que une femme du Nord
Martha derumeaux parcours tout à fait
exceptionnel soit également panthéonisé
je le fais avec un certain nombre
d'autres parlementaires de toute
sensibilité politique j'espère que nous
aboutirons que le Président de la
République accédera notre demande elle
ne sage est passée vous serez à Lille
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pour nos
merci beaucoup je vais remercier pomme
qui était avec nous pommes dossier
spécial dans toutes les journaux du
groupe Centre France l'égalité c'est
pour quand c'est à dire dans vos
journaux merci beaucoup comme la brousse
d'avoir été avec nous et merci merci
beaucoup Martine filleul merci d'être
venu nous voir ce matin c'était un
plaisir de vous recevoir dans 20 minutes
on va continuer notre édition spéciale
évidemment réforme des retraites on fera
le point sur la mobilisation dans nos
régions notamment mais d'abord je vous
le disais c'est Jean-François Copé qui
va vous succéder merci à vous